that's a serious note though i've driven
all across the country i got i got a
ticket this morning i gotta take it this
morning
shocker i know i'm just it's a public
announcement i got exactly like my 200
ticket hey guys uh not breaking news
packing another traffic ticket
where were you going 170 and a thousand
anyway it's a terrible ticket but i got
to take it this morning and we have to
now work on this with my ticket but
anyways so one thing about florida i got
to give credit to
the worst drivers oh my ever expected i
kind of
cut off something dude like a guy a girl
cut me off yesterday i'm not even
kidding with you i'm just
she's like this
i've never seen this in my life i'm just
looking at her and she's like apologies
i'm like i accept the apology but this
is seriously weird i've never seen then
today this morning a guy cuts up it's
five lane federal i'm coming up from the
furthest lane to the right
to the left turn he just straight up
goes like this yeah i mean so so the
credit goes to they're either nascar
drivers get trained here
formula one drivers they just suck when
they do that do you know the reasons why
tell us think about it we've got
retirees galore yeah there's 80 year
olds all these three were under 40. no i
don't accept that you have a lot of
tourists that are just kind of like
going you have a lot of immigrants a lot
of
latinos especially coming from nah
people just don't know
fyi those are some of the best drivers
because you have to learn how to drive
without laws and lights and that's right
they're they're they're the big okay i
don't know why more latino drivers won
the nascar i don't understand why they
don't like there's got to be a
recruitment you got to go to like a you
got to go somebody's got to go to tj
because they don't let low riders in
nascar pass
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you